les autochtones américains et canadiens
ont-ils des droits pour traverser la
frontière entre les deux pays
pour répondre à ta question eric en 1794
via un traité qui s'appelle jeff tweedy
où le traité de jais qui a été signé
entre l'empiré britannique et les états
unis qui venait nouvellement d'être
créée ça permettait dans le fond de
continuer un peu l'économie entre ces
deux nations look était quand même assez
en chicane mais de pouvoir voir quand
même la distinction qui existait entre
le canada et les états unis à l'époque
sauf que dans ce traité l'oeil quand
même une provision qui a été créé pour
les autochtones et c'était de pouvoir
permettre le libre passage entre la
frontière canadienne et américaine des
trappeurs chasseurs autochtone pour
continuer justement la trappe et la
traite des fourrures qui existait
jusqu'en le long du mississippi pour
pouvoir bénéficier du traité de j'ai
aujourd'hui il faut du côté américain
pouvoir prouver qu'on a 50 % de 101
tient ce qui est pas là même une gestion
de l'identité autochtone qu'on a au
canada mais ça demande juste de proches
prouver ça alors ça permet de prendre
traversé la frontière de façon libre et
pendant très longtemps même on pouvait
le faire sans nécessairement utiliser la
pièce quel passeport mais utiliser la
carte de statut ce qui est très
compliqué parce que depuis 2001 la cour
suprême a reconnu qu'il ya ce n'est pas
un droit ancestral que de pouvoir
traverser les frontières sans payer de
taxes et d'impôts donc on dirait que ça
le diminuer l'impact et le pouvoir que
le traité de gea
mais la reconnaissance que les
communautés autochtones en ont et un de
libre passage entre deux territoires qui
étaient traditionnellement les leurs et
là je pense particulièrement à la
communauté dacquois assassiné et à aux
postes frontaliers qui existe là et
beaucoup de pression mais aussi beaucoup
de tensions qui ont
monter à la surface justement suite à au
non respect habituel du traité de jais
qui était que les gens de la nation
mohawk pouvait traverser seulement avec
leurs passeports aux tno chauny ou avec
leur carte de banque
s'il disait la carte de bande donc on
voit que la responsabilité est pris
beaucoup plus du côté américain où est
ce qu'on peut penser ou est-ce qu'on
peut même aller travailler aux états
unis sous le traité de g mais au canada
il ya un travail qui se fait de ne pas
reconnaître ce traité leur de façon
aussi libre et là je n'oserais même pas
rentrer dans la montée de l'intolérance
qui vient avec le gouvernement de donald
trump ou même le racisme automatisé que
demander aux frontières fait que le
passage des premières nations et des
peuples autochtones est de plus en plus
difficile entre la frontière canadienne
et américaine
alors tu comprends c'est compliqué mais
c'est quand même un sujet d'avenir parce
que c'est une question de pouvoir passer
librement sur des territoires
autochtones
j'espère y avoir répondu à votre
question j'espère que vous allez
partager cette chronique et j'espère que
vous allez poser d'autres questions et
n'hésitez pas vous avez formé autour de
vous et on vous souhaite une belle
semaine à paroles autochtone